what happened um the last time you got
shot down
um the last the last time because i was
in in buddha
yeah north of uh one bit one
and i
insert the team and came back when i
came back i
just like when you are
when you are in service for a long time
or in combat for a long time
you have some feeling i would say it's a
sixth feeling and i feel something wrong
on the ground
you're down in the very jungle so i from
uh 1500 feet i go down
to check it uh
at about 500 feet they start to shoot at
me
and this is this when you're trying to
extract them or is this during the
insert
he dropped him off he's coming back from
another okay so after you drop them off
you're halfway home yeah and you decide
you're gonna go look on the ground
yeah and you start getting instinct yeah
and
i i got mad and
i said a big zigzag fly and i skipped
the line on fire
and uh i got mad i said that this is my
land and i take care of it
or why you go down to shoot at me so i
come back
and shoot and i got hit again
and the shopper caught fire
the realm hit the fuel tank and then the
fuel ignites
and the fire comes from the fuel tank
into the cabin
he's at 500 feet trying to keep the
aircraft stable to land
while on fire
and i was on top of the frame the frames
coming from the
uh came up from the cabin to the carpet
and i
if i use it i land right at the right or
right
on the same way around there it is the
uh it will be okay but uh i don't want
it to be get caught
so i keep fighting like i do uh buddha
so so your plane's on so you're your
helicopter's on fire i'm fine you could
crack
you could land right but you don't want
to get caught
no because that's going to be horror and
uh
i tried to get back to a boot up and
the frame could the flame keep her keep
burning
and one time
it was so hard that
i let i left all of the control
the corrective and cyclic i have it i
keep my my hand and my at my chest when
i saw the
when i left the cycling
then the shop would start to dive down
and i i saw the
route coming up and
i said i just tell the thing in my head
that
it's on it's over but
when it comes close to the treetop
the the instinct of uh
survival pushed me to grab the cyclic
and pull it back
and he said the chopper was diving down
and then
suddenly when i pulled the cycling back
so so hard
and it came up i thought that the
main road that would come off but he
didn't and i saw
i saw it and i labeled it and so
the shop is the knight in again so
it it's a little like it tried like a
syn line in the sky
and finally i make a glass landing
in uh in the open area
so the the the in the handles were so
hot that you couldn't hold on to them no
but then
at the last minute survival instinct
yeah
you knew what you had to do in order to
get some kind of a landing so you just
grabbed those and when i saw the
algae i was flying at the 80 80 nautical
mile
and it was 90 nautical mile and
i moved the cycle to the right and
pushed the
right pillow all the way down and so the
uh the shuffle at the 90 north of my
make a 360 degree
so quickly that i thought the care the
tailbone came off
but they didn't and it started to settle
down
and now and i touched down very smooth
and but it still starts still running
so he hit the tree and on the wheel came
off
the blade came off and when he stopped i
i grabbed the seatbelt
lock and i pull it
but instead but i can pull my finger
open and
for three times i use my left hand and
my left elbow
to hit the buckle and they
said the uh lock and i grabbed
the handle of the window because when
i make a class it run and they had the
window rent for move over
and close it so i grabbed the handle of
the window
pull it back but it happened i like the
on the seat belt
i grab it but the finger open but
couldn't hold the
handle because the skin was burning
so i used my my shoulder to hit the
window
and i broke the window out i jumped out
when i jumped out i saw
from knee down
they are the material which came out
with burnout except the uh zipper
remained
and the uh the probe is still burning
so i wrote down on the grass wet grass
and to put it off and after it
was off i couldn't stand up
and my crew chip ran by and grabbed me
up and
me the uh guide me to the rescue shop
the number three number three kingdom
so then you get on the number three king
b they get you out of there
and you obviously go straight to the
hospital they
they brought me back to the
middle to the hospital it was
a military hospital in saigon
and i stayed there for it
until 11
a.m to next morning
next morning the uh one king
one pilot over king b pilot from dna
fuel bank with the
american advice brought me to turkey
hospital
and that well i stayed for eight months
and what was that process like those
next eight months
oh they uh amputate my uh hand
and make a six spin grab on my leg
because my life when i was in the
hospital and they
the day the the doctor doctor smith
he amputated my hand i
i i asked him how about my leg he said
oh
he didn't know until after the
after the operation did they amputate
both your hands at the same time
yes
and then what was the what was the plan
from there
what what happened after that after that
i
go back and forth for faker for eight
months
no the treatment mentions about four or
five months
but after that i will make it forward up
to the house for two days
for the doctor to try to check it
and after that after all the treatment
they
sent me back to the vietnamese hospital
and at some point i know you had a
brother that was a
ae1 pilot right he's a a1 pilot yeah
and what happened with him he was on the
95 mission and
he was missing that's all right we know
95 business were across the fence also
right no
no he was missing about around about
uh 30 kilometers north of uh
now attending
kenyan northern